celebrities playing other celebrities
parodies of parodies and a send-up of
that drug scene from every music biopic
weird the Al Yankovic story almost has
too many self-referential jokes so these
might have slipped by
not only are most of the story beats
character arcs and career steps in weird
the Al Yankovic story patently false but
the film also takes place in a fictional
World specifically the film's reality
feels like the real world except for the
fact that cool people celebrities and
rebellious teenagers are all really into
accordions and polka music what have we
told you about listening to that garbage
weird also includes an odd to how other
musical biopics depicts the future star
clashing with their parents over noisy
newfangled rock and roll music in the
movie Al's father is vehemently opposed
to his son playing the accordion however
Al's mother nurses her son's deep-rooted
desire to play The Forbidden instrument
giving him one as a gift from then on he
practices in secret when he's a teenager
Al's friends encourage him to sneak out
and attend a raucous polka party where
he impresses a gaggle of high schoolers
with his accordion prowess until the
police show up and shut it all down
young Yankovic is otherwise forced to
read accordion World apparently a very
popular magazine in this universe snuck
inside a school textbook radio DJ and
Mentor figure Dr Demento declares that
his new client is in need of a stage
name because Al Yankovic just isn't
going to cut it Yankovic has just
performed and dazzled the crowd with I
love Rocky Rogue his parody of Joan Jett
and the Blackhearts I love rock and roll
right there in the dressing room of a
sketchy bar Demento gives Al one option
and one option only giving birth to the
professional life of the newly named
Weird Al Yankovic it's a simple trick
the addition of one descriptive word to
the musician's real name but it's one
rooted in reality weird
Al Yankovic
I love it Dr Demento tells Al that
previous funny musicians nervous norvus
and wild man Fisher Never Would Have
Made It big without their stage names
while those sound like setup names to
frame the similar Weird Al they're both
real people Jimmy Drake also known as
nervous norvus scored a top 10 hit in
1956 with transfusion a celebration of
reckless driving meanwhile Fisher was a
comical Outsider musician and street
performer in the 1960s both played the
kind of music that would have been heard
on the real Dr demento's radio show
Weird Al Yankovic finds himself on the
verge of Fame after being discovered by
novelty song disc jockey Dr Demento who
offers to Shepherd him into the upper
echelons of Fame and Fortune the first
stop is a pool party at demento's
palatial mansion and young Al is dazzled
by all the big time celebrities in
attendance the famous people many of
them played by other famous people pop
up on screen so quickly and for such a
short period of time that it's easy for
viewers to miss at least a couple while
their brains process who they just
spotted the two guys in red flower pot
hats sitting on Deck chairs when Al
Rives are supposed to be members of Devo
who the real Yankovic would later parody
with dare to be stupid then he sees
Elton John in the outfit he wore on the
cover of his greatest hits collection
talking with 70s Star John Denver other
stars pop in silently including David
Bowie Elvira Frank Zappa Kate Pearson of
The B-52s and Alice Cooper who is played
by Akiva Shafer of Comedy music group
The Lonely Island Al interacts with a
few other star party guests including
Pee-wee Herman Salvador Dali Wolfman
Jack who's played by Jack Black and Andy
Warhol portrayed by Conan O'Brien I give
him 15 minutes weird the yellow Yankovic
story boasts a lot of cameos Yankovic is
a modern comedy Legend and many famous
fans colleagues and Comedy Big Shots
shopped be homage in the film's very
first scene Flash Forward shows Alan
nearly dying in a hospital an experience
that will inspire his Madonna parody
Like a Surgeon and features lin-manuel
of Miranda playing an exasperated and
emotional ER surgeon the Miranda
appearance also has roots in Weird Al's
music in 2018 Yankovic compiled one of
his signature polka medleys out of songs
from Miranda's Broadway musical Mega hit
Hamilton Al frequently butts heads with
two record Executives Ben and Tony
Scotty those are the real names of the
guys behind Yankovic's longtime label
Scotty Brothers records but they're
portrayed by wolf Forte and Yankovic
himself in the climactic Grammy Award
scene Al waits in the audience for his
category to be called out and he's
accompanied by a woman Yankovic's real
wife Suzanne krajewski portrays the fake
Yankovic State weird the Al Yankovic
story is a proudly and hilariously
inaccurate over-the-top biopic about the
rise and invented fall of Weird Al it
also functions as a not not at all true
story of fellow emergent musical
Superstar Madonna betrayed by Westworld
star Evan Rachel Wood Madonna romances
Yankovic for personal gain as she wants
him to parody her songs to boost her own
album sales Madonna ends up sending him
on a road of boozing and
self-destruction and winds up taking
over Pablo Escobar's powerful
International drug trafficking cartel
after Al guns him down finding herself
surrounded by towers of cocaine bricks
Madonna realizes that the money she's
made as a pop star pales in comparison
to the fortune she could earn
controlling the global illicit drug
trade Al turns down her offer to run the
cartel with her despite her persuasive
argument I wrote the music industry when
you can rule the world of course this is
a Sly reference to the real Madonna's
extreme sense of purpose and ambition
she became one of the biggest stars on
the planet and that's something she told
everyone she do early in her career
after performing on American Bandstand
in 1984 host Dick Clark asked Madonna
what her dreams were she had a simple
answer to rule the world Madonna's plot
in weird is rooted in some truth too
Yankovic said on The Tonight Show
starring Jimmy Fallon that there's
something called the Yankovic bump
Yankovic told Fallon that his Nirvana
parody resulted in a phone call from
Ben's record label thanking Yankovic for
the parody which resulted in the label
selling another million units of
Nirvana's never mind every rock music
biopic seems to include a psychedelic
scene that inspires an epiphany and
weird is no exception not only does it
set up the untrue story of how Weird Al
Yankovic conceived one of his most
popular songs but it establishes a
subtle running gag at the expense of
another pop Superstar while fretting
over his estrangement from his father Al
munches on chips and guacamole which
unbeknownst to him Dr Demento has laced
with LSD Al goes on a Trippy Vision
Quest during which Dr Demento casually
offers him a bowl of cap and crunch and
then a bowl of racing brand of course
those are references to Yankovic's 1984
hit eat it which includes the lyrics how
come you're always such a fussy young
man don't want no Captain Crunch don't
want no Raisin Bran eat it is a parody
of Michael Jackson's 1983 single beat it
but in The fictionalized Narrative of
weird eat it actually came first
Yankovic is extremely proud of his
original single and becomes angered by
the misconception that his version came
second this sends Yankovic into a rage
with his closest allies wondering why he
wouldn't want to be forever associated
with the King of Pop you're telling me
Michael Jackson recorded a parody of my
song It's a reference to Yankovic's real
life tendency to parody Jackson's hits
backed up by many more references to
Jackson throughout the film for instance
when Al hallucinates he imagines himself
playing guitar inside of an egg
referencing the line in beat it get
yourself an egg and beat it later in the
movie Al mother points out that she's
gained weight responding to polite
denials from her husband and son she
proclaims that she's fat and they know
it this is a reference to the chorus of
fat Yankovic's parody of Jackson's back
every famous musician biopic includes a
moment when the fame gets too much
because weird is a parody it decides to
send up the Trope itself as well as one
of its most memorable executions Al
reaches a point where he can't cope with
Fame it's trappings and his personal
demons any longer while on stage one
night he stops performing his usual fear
of funny songs and starts ranting raving
about how he can't let his father push
him around while his band breaks into
some generic psychedelic music he drinks
whiskey from the bottle while clad in
only leather pants then asks the crowd
you want to see it
this moment is based on a similar
on-stage meltdown scene from Oliver
Stone's 1991 movie The Doors in which a
drunk Jim Morrison antagonizes the
audience and Promises to expose himself
despite the threat of arrest Morrison
really did that and he was arrested in
1969 in Miami-Dade County for lewd
Behavior the same place owls breakdown
and apprehension occurs and we're the
big difference is that Morrison dropped
his pants whereas Al just produces his
accordion because Weird Al Yankovic
obtains his long-stated goal in the
movie he must die immediately the film
concludes that the 1985 Grammy Awards
although the generic stage decorations
and bespoke trophies suggest filmmakers
didn't secure the rights to use official
Grammy imagery Diana Ross and Hulk Hogan
present the final and thus most
important category which is perhaps not
technically the best but arguably the
most famous accordion player in an
extremely specific genre of music that
is exactly what Young Al said he wanted
to be early in the film before he found
Fame and Fortune
[Music]
stop this is a genre of music of course
Weird Al Yankovic wins to the livid
Chagrin of the other nominee an unnamed
figure who is almost certainly meant to
be Prince When Weird Al defeats him he
angrily leaves the auditorium this is
probably an allusion to the history
between Yankovic and the late Prince
according to people Yankovic came up
with parodies of Let's Go Crazy in 1999
kiss and when doves cry and random
all-pass Prince for his approval who
apparently always said no Weird Al
Yankovic's parodies original songs and
movies are all represented in weird the
yali Yankovic Story by way of discreetly
placed Easter eggs when Madonna and Al
lay in bed after making love for the
first time the camera catches a hanging
mirror adorned with the quote if money
can't buy happiness I guess I'll have to
rent it it's attributed to Weird Al
Yankovic and is taken from his 1986
original This Is The Life later on after
drug lord Pablo Escobar kidnaps Madonna
as a way to lure owl to Colombia to
perform at his birthday party elf stocks
and Battles Through the Jungle this is
likely an allusion to the Indiana Jones
intro and the Rambo inspired sequence
from Yankovic's movie UHF when Al meets
Escobar the latter gushes that he
obtained every Weird Al Yankovic album
from the Columbia House record club
which is a reference to Yankovic's 1999
song Albuquerque finally after Al is
assassinated at the 1985 Grammy Awards
Madonna visits the grave of her former
lover for a brief moment the camera
catches Al's Tombstone which reveals
that in 1985 the edit singer didn't so
much die but rather he ate it
[Music]